[Música]
hola bienvenidos a este programa
especial del debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález el 2021 marco un
año más en el que el terrorismo ocupó
nuevamente los principales titulares de
la prensa internacional desde coche
bombas en mogadiscio la capital de
somalia ataques suicidas en bagdad y
kabul apuñalamientos masivos en oakland
tokio y würzburgo hasta tiroteos en
diferentes lugares del planeta las
formas en las que el terrorismo se ha
presentado han cambiado y se han
modernizado y también se han tecnificado
este 2021 coincide también con la
conmemoración de los 20 años del ataque
terrorista a las torres gemelas en nueva
york que provocó una respuesta del
planeta muy vulnerable en ese momento
que mostró una cierta solidaridad con
eeuu en su lucha contra el terrorismo
que llevó a la invasión de afganistán
para capturar al líder de al-qaeda osama
bin laden dicho líder murió justamente
en un operativo anti terrorista en
pakistán unos años después pero 20 años
después las tropas de eeuu abandonaron
ese país asiático y afganos volvió a
quedar en manos del talibán un grupo
presuntamente ligado con redes
terroristas a nivel internacional en el
2021 como se libró la lucha contra el
terrorismo qué papel está jugando eeuu
como país abanderado de esta lucha a
nivel internacional cómo ha lidiado
europa con el terrorismo en su
territorio que hay de los grupos
terroristas en la actualidad nos quedan
muchas preguntas como ustedes pueden ver
muchas preguntas sobre la mesa y vamos a
hacer entonces el balance de la lucha
terrorista en el 2021 ese es nuestro
tema de análisis en este especial del
debate de france 24 para analizar este
tema hemos invitado a cristian heard
bolín jaime ls director del instituto
catalán internacional para la paz está
en la ciudad de barcelona en españa
también está con nosotros fernando coche
él es analista de inteligencia y riesgos
a la seguridad nacional es experto en
terrorismo y crímenes de odio está en la
ciudad de madrid la capital española y
aquí en el estudio de france 24 nos
acompaña oscar palmas él es profesor de
la facultad de estudios internacionales
políticos y urbanos de la universidad
del rosario que está ubicada en
de bogotá en colombia ustedes nuestros
televidentes también pueden participar
en este debate con todos sus comentarios
y preguntas los pueden hacer a través de
las redes sociales no se encuentran en
facebook en instagram en twitter estamos
como france24
santi logo que es mi cuenta personal les
recuerdo que la etiqueta es numeral el
debate efe 24 esperamos todos sus
comentarios y sus preguntas en torno a
este tema de este programa especial del
debate de france 24 vamos a comenzar
entonces en la ciudad de barcelona
cristian allí en la capital catalana
comienzo por preguntarle por el balance
del 2021 qué escenario tiene en este
momento entonces la lucha terrorista o
antiterrorista y sobre cómo el
terrorismo se ha modificado a lo largo
de estos 20 años desde el atentado del
11 de septiembre a las torres gemelas en
la ciudad de nueva york que marcó un
antes y un después en la lucha
antiterrorista a nivel internacional
muchas gracias sin lugar a dudas
el helecho que más marca el año 2021 ha
sido el triunfo de los talibanes en la
guerra civil de afganistán una guerra
que arranca precisamente como
consecuencia del ataque terrorista a las
torres gemelas veinte años después y que
sin embargo acaba en un fracaso
estrepitoso en el intento de
bueno básicamente una operación
internacional multilateral pero con unos
objetivos que incluso muchos dirían que
son difusos porque habían objetivos
diferentes en esa misma operación el
caso es que en y acaba acaba acaba
fracasando y yo creo que todavía es
incluso de pronto temprano para medir
las consecuencias de ese cambio en el
contexto específico de afganistán pero
también en la en la la geografía de su
alrededor pero incluso también en la
conceptualización de la política
exterior de eeuu de la unión europea y
de otros países que se han involucrado
en ese contexto aparte de ese episodio
pues hacía cierto tiempo que estamos
observando una evolución importante en
relación a los temas del terrorismo el
terrorismo siempre es muy políticamente
sensible cuando se utiliza porque cuando
no hay una definición en un estándar
internacionalmente acordado pues
entonces se convierte en muy fácilmente
una arma arrojadiza política y es
difícil a veces también perderlas en
tener en cuenta
porciones de las
situaciones y las tecnologías que
podemos ir comentando a lo largo de este
programa claro lo de la palabra ahora a
fernando coche en la ciudad de madrid
también para conocer su opinión y el
balance que usted hace de este 2021 2021
en torno a la lucha terrorista a nivel
internacional ya vamos a analizar más
adelante cómo se ha ido modificando pero
sus impresiones para comenzar
hola buenas noches desde desde madrid
bueno realmente el terrorismo a nivel
internacional ha cambiado en cuanto a su
denominación se habla de guerras
híbridas de conflictos asimétricos de
zonas grises de penetración o
quintacolumnismo por parte de gobiernos
que apoyan a ciertos grupos terroristas
o que fingen ser terroristas para
programar procesos geopolíticos pero es
obvio que si ponemos una balanza no sólo
por el tema del can y stan que no es un
país un conjunto de etnias territoriales
que tienen una lucha entre ellas pero
desde hace 2000 años y que
ocasionalmente sobre todo cuando han
recibido ataques externos se ha
configurado como país es por tanto
organizar en sí mismo no es un país de
lo que se llama por geopolíticamente una
estructura exprés durán real de un país
sino un estado fallido bueno pues el
terrorismo yo creo que si bien no ha
ganado o no está ganando si es cierto
que está generando haciendo una serie de
heridas bastante importantes a nivel
internacional porque evidentemente desde
la suma technión y tecnificación en las
torres gemelas o el aprovechamiento de
la debilidad de las torres gemelas a
partir de ahí se vio una evolución en la
que se usó medios de comunicación
narrativas y contra narrativas por parte
del das o por parte de otros grupos como
boko haram con el secuestro de
adolescentes y a partir de ahí luego
vídeo una época de los mal llamados
lobos solitarios y al ahora seguro otra
vez a un proceso de
unificación ojeo pollicita ción de lo
que son los grupos terroristas o grupos
radicales claro y en ese momento hoy lo
que estamos es viendo que de nuevo hay
una especie de confluencia de relaciones
en esos grupos el talibán tiene ya
acuerdos con los integristas yihadistas
del cáucaso y en acuerdos con él y xisca
tiene acuerdo con los yemeníes útiles en
acuerdos con mucha gente para evitar
conflictos entre ellos por tanto no es
tan fácil de denominar que es lo que
está ocurriendo en estos momentos bueno
para completar esta primera ronda para
analizar el panorama general finalizó
con oscar palmas aquí en el estudio de
france 24 bienvenido sus impresiones
sobre este 2021 sobre la lucha
antiterrorista y lo que ha significado
para el mundo este año
y gracias ante algún saludo para todos
en efecto si nosotros miramos las cifras
de bajas de muertes por terrorismo vemos
un descenso desde el año 2014 hasta acá
hay una reducción del número de bajas de
muertos causadas por el terrorismo y eso
puede obedecer a una cosa interesante y
es que cada vez más vemos menos
atentados tipo 11 de septiembre grandes
atentados espectaculares con un número
de bajas muy alto y más atentados tipo
utilización de un cuchillo utilización
de un arma las personas que toman un
carro ya atropellan a las personas
entonces vemos una una reducción de unos
países más afectados que otros y
afganistán es el estado más afectado por
el terrorismo este año un poco también
en siria irak hay un descenso de cierta
forma en las actividades de terrorismo
en la zona del norte de áfrica en el
magreb pero una intensificación en el
áfrica sub-sahariana
con algunos casos por supuesto en
américa latina' el caso de colombia que
sigue siendo importante en términos de
terrorismo
con unos cambios también en la
tecnificación lo que se mencionaba
anteriormente
y bueno sin embargo sigue siendo por
supuesto un fenómeno preocupante con
ciertas organizaciones
características protagonistas del
fenómeno este año sobre todo talibán un
leve descenso de las actividades de boko
haram de al shabab pero por supuesto con
una actividad muy grande en afganistán
oscar sigo con usted aquí en el estudio
de france 24 y doy paso al siguiente
punto que quiero analizar y es el avance
que ha tenido es muy distinto el
terrorismo que vimos hace 20 años que ya
vamos a ver lo que dejó el 11 de
septiembre para la historia y lo que nos
ha enseñado a hoy en día pero como está
el terrorismo y en términos de
tecnología la forma de reclutar a las
personas que llevan a sus filas y
también el entrelazamiento que se está
dando entre las diferentes
organizaciones sobre todo en el medio
oriente en la zona del sahel
y bueno también tengo que mencionar
afganistán por supuesto uno de nuestros
invitados hablaba de algunos grupos
también en el sur del cáucaso
como se están entrelazando porque
también hacen uso de las redes sociales
veíamos a un un grupo talibán que llegó
al poder otra vez en afganistán dando
ruedas de prensa dando conferencias
entrevistas hablando en inglés dando
entrevistas a medios internacionales
cuando antes verle la cara a los
integrantes del talibán era muy difícil
han cambiado mucho en efecto santiago
hay algunas cosas que se mantienen como
siempre se han mantenido el uso
explosivo se ilustre carrobombas eso eso
sigue siendo una tendencia actual y
siempre lo ha sido en el terrorismo pero
si hay una utilización por ejemplo del
ciberespacio de las redes sociales como
usted mencionaba al qaeda comenzó a
hacer muy buen uso del internet pero en
ese caso sobre todo eran salas de chat
espacios de conversación el estado
islámico avanza un poquito más y va a
utilizar redes sociales ahí sí estamos
hablando los vídeos los vídeos twitter
youtube la transmisión de estos dos que
son una producción casi julia y
hollywoodense para mandar un mensaje
para convencer a la gente de su lucha y
demás entonces si hay una utilización
del ciberespacio a favor de las
organizaciones terroristas y eso mismo
permite esa interconexión de la cual
usted hablaba entonces lo que vemos
desde al qaeda es que no existe una
organización como tal sino que existe
una red de redes entonces son una serie
de grupos que están interconectados que
comparten mucho la narrativa el discurso
sobre todo porque hay una difusión del
discurso a través del ciberespacio
entonces puede que un jefe de una
organización no sea un comandante
operativo propiamente dicho pero si es
un líder e inspiracional entonces manda
unos mensajes manda unos vídeos y la
gente que está en muchas partes del
mundo podríamos estar hablando de
personas de segunda tercera generación
de descendientes musulmanes en europa
están escuchando eso y dicen yo tengo
que actuar serios del ciberespacio
aparecía ahí como una dimensión
importante aún así hay diferencias en el
discurso
al qaeda no tiene una relación cercana
por ejemplo con el estado islámico sobre
todo cuando está en su apogeo en el este
de siria y en el norte de irak durante
los momentos más álgidos de la guerra en
siria pasó al de la palabra fernando
coche voy a hacer la ronda a la inversa
preguntándole sobre los avances la hay
modificaciones en la forma en que el
terrorismo se está presentando ahora ya
lo mencionaba no son estos ataques
gigantescos como los del 11 de
septiembre en eeuu en que ha cambiado la
metodología para aterrorizar a la
humanidad
la metodología ha cambiado al mismo
ritmo que cambia la sociedad o inicia el
compañero que está en el estudio
evidentemente es un problema de
narrativas y contra narrativas
evidentemente los talibanes que es el
grupo que parece ser que ha creado mejor
narrativa y contra narrativa hemos
limpios negros aseados vemos con
conferencias en múltiples idiomas pero
el comportamiento lo que se llamaría la
epistemología o el fundamento
conductual cognitiva conductual del
terrorismo
por parte de los talibanes sigue siendo
un porqué talibán jamás se fue el
talibán permaneció penetrando en el
ejército de la sociedad para a partir de
ahí recuperar el peso en la sociedad de
los talibanes de sociedad afgana fruto
de la corrupción fruto muchos temas que
no vamos a tratar en este momento lo que
se ha cambiado no sólo es el
ciberespacio y el modelo de uso de
narrativas y contra narrativas sino
también el uso de las nuevas tecnologías
para lo que realmente es el terrorismo
no solo las difusiones de imágenes o de
revistas sino la de la recluta el
reclutamiento la asesoramiento la
comunicación entre los grupos
terroristas en twitter en facebook en
instagram en muchos sistemas de redes
sociales se crean foros que duran
durante 45 minutos con una clave
determinada y desaparecen inmediatamente
para una vez que ya han dado las órdenes
o las instrucciones evitar el rastreo
por parte de las fuerzas y cuerpos del
estado de los ejércitos a los servicios
de inteligencia y eso es realmente el
terrorismo que ha cambiado ha cambiado
la metodología desde el punto de vista
del uso técnico pero ha cambiado el ni
la epistemología
variables de reclutamiento es decir el
techo de cristal que no se cumple en
europa y que por tanto los desarraigados
de ciertas culturas no consiguen
penetrar el abandono social de ciertas
zonas por parte de los gobiernos también
porque no en la lucha de tres no haya
civilizaciones sino en tres formas
diferentes de percibir la realidad el
fracaso estrepitoso de lo que es el mal
llamado primer mundo y sus factores
democráticos es un conjunto de cosas que
provocan que cierta gente donde no
encuentra sentido y no necesariamente
musulmanes
y busca su identidad allí donde estaba
su familia si acaso los musulmanes y
allí donde se le genera una identidad
más fuerte más de un colectivo férreo
identitario y que permite un desarrollo
digámoslo así personal y es el cambio no
sólo el tecnológico sino el social
asociado el tecnológico y asociado clara
bien variable que es el terrorismo es la
generación de miedo de conflicto y de
problemas allí donde está el estado
claro importante ese punto fernando allí
en la ciudad de madrid vamos ahora hasta
barcelona cristian en su opinión sobre
sobre estos avances sobre esta
percepción del terrorismo religioso pero
también ahora se habla de terrorismo
desde la política desde el narcotráfico
que lo podríamos analizar yo creo que
cuando miremos el caso de américa latina
se ha diversificado también las formas
de terrorismo entonces a lo largo de
estos 20 años como lo vio usted
bueno más que diversificar como decía
ahora fernando corcho pues en los
desarrollos tecnológicos y demás o se
están utilizando muy bien pero luego hay
las formas clásicas que siempre que
sirven existido y que por durán es
complejo analiza el tema el terrorismo
porque en algunos contextos en el
impacto es por el número de víctimas y
aquí quiero llevar a colación por
ejemplo el caso de méxico
específicamente en méxico muere más
gente asesinada en contexto democrático
que en afganistán en estos últimos años
el peor conflicto armado que existía
aquí estamos hablando de cantidades de
muertes y de violencia pero al mismo
tiempo otro fenómeno que estamos
observando estos últimos años a raíz del
incremento de polarización social y
política en las democracias más
consolidadas sobre todo en eeuu pero
también un poco en europa es un
terrorismo que no en sino en cifras en
cantidades pero si por el lugar donde se
da pues se les hace saltar todas las
alarmas que es el terrorismo de extrema
derecha
que además está teniendo en contextos
estadísticas de eeuu por ejemplo dicen
que hay un cierto hay una cierta
comprensión social a una cierta
justificación de que en algún momento de
hablar la polis a la violencia puede
estar justificada incluso en tu propio
territorio
bueno esos son señales de alarma harán
pues pues que sé que están se que están
saltando lógicamente por razones muy
diferentes a casa de los casos de
afganistán de siria de mexico que
hablábamos antes cristian continuó con
usted en la ciudad de barcelona
ya que usted toca el tema de eeuu viene
aquí a la mesa precisamente esta
conmemoración de los 20 años de haber
ocurrido el atentado del 11 de
septiembre de nueva york cambió por
completo la historia de eeuu y el mundo
en muchas maneras y muchos dicen que es
un punto de partida importante en la
historia
desde su perspectiva a eeuu durante
estos 20 años con una ocupación en
afganistán una retirada que fue bastante
criticada y bochornosa que dejó en
entredicho a eeuu en la escena
internacional
balance se puede hacer de esa lucha
antiterrorista liderada por eeuu que
como decía yo en la introducción se
mostró en un escenario de vulnerabilidad
del planeta y que el mundo entero apoyó
a eeuu pero vemos las consecuencias y
los resultados 20 años después si no son
los más satisfactorios o como los ve
usted
bueno en la línea lo que comentaba antes
de la dificultad de de reducir el tema
del terrorismo a unas pocas nociones a
unos pocos con casos concretos porque en
bajo un término entran situaciones
completamente diferentes
entonces en los propios eeuu al cabo de
unos pocos años se dieron cuenta que esa
idea de la guerra global contra el
terrorismo era una guerra muy abstracta
y con un enfoque muy determinado y
finalmente se
demostró que no solamente no era eficaz
sino que además la máxima que suelen
utilizar los estados que es que nunca
vamos a negociar con los terroristas
pues los propios eeuu empezaron a
negociar con los talibanes unos cuantos
años después de arrancar con la guerra
pero además que mientras estaban
llevando la guerra global contra el
terror se estaba fraguando en su
interior unas tensiones sociales
políticas por un montón de razones muy
complejas por agravios reales o
percibidos por imaginarios como
comentaban también el compañero que
hacen qué bueno es que si incluso se
había perdido de las dimensiones del
enfoque estamos viendo para fuera y no
tanto para adentro y ahora pues hay un
repensar a escala global en todos los
países
oscar aquí en el estudio de france24
esta política y este discurso
antiterrorista en eeuu que tanto ha sido
de verdad una necesidad del país por
defender su soberanía su dignidad
internacional o un discurso que sirva
para camuflar muchos problemas que
internamente como dice christian hay en
barcelona
santiago yo creo que estados unidos
cometió un error en la concepción de la
lucha y cuando uno ve que suceden los
ataques del 11 de septiembre y en ese
momento inicia una estrategia para
desarticular las redes del terrorismo
global lo que uno no se imagina
y vamos a abrir escenarios de guerra por
todo la y menos en irak entonces uno
pensaría la estrategia para luchar
contra el terrorismo va por el lado de
compartir información de inteligencia de
ubicar tal vez algunos agentes
independientemente de cuál agencia en
escenarios específicos para sacar
información de inteligencia es un
trabajo muy intenso de la inteligencia
muy intenso de la inteligencia
y sin embargo lo que hace eeuu es abrir
escenarios de guerra en afganistán lo
cual se entiende porque el régimen
talibán estaba protegiendo a osama bin
laden y al qaeda sin duda alguna pero
luego abre ese escenario de una guerra
no necesaria en irak y lo que termina
haciendo es irónicamente abriéndole un
escenario espectacular a los terroristas
para profundizar su discurso su
reclutamiento y todo lo demás entonces
claro se crea todo este discurso de la
lucha contra el terrorismo con una serie
de medidas pero en realidad no están
siendo efectivas porque lo que estamos
haciendo es motivar a más terroristas a
sumarse a las redes de terrorismo por
las acciones mismas que nosotros estamos
provocando detrás de esto puede haber un
interés en
tener las plataformas de inteligencia de
vigilancia al interior del estado el
aumento de la seguridad del departamento
de homeland security que se crea nuevo
en ese momento para realizar una serie
de actividades y políticas pero muy
lejos de lo que sería una guerra
efectiva contra unas redes de terrorismo
claro fernando de la ciudad de madre y
la gran pregunta que se ha hecho la
gente después de esa retirada de es 20
años después de lucha y presencia de
eeuu el que ganó fue el talibán
bueno realmente el talibán nunca perdió
efectivamente vamos a ver hay una
pequeña discrepancia respecto a que
oscar ha dicho excelentemente y es que
eeuu el mundo piensa que fue a
afganistán como también fue a ir aquí a
siria para atacar al terrorismo
internacional y asegurar el planeta
contra ese un movimiento globalizado del
terrorismo cosa que es falsa en la
propia normativa de la holland security
y de la force otro lado de eeuu
establece que lo que van a hacer en
afganistán fundamentalmente es luchar
contra aquellos que han amenazado su
territorio el momento que los talibanes
dicen que no van a luchar ni van a
favorecer el ataque al territorio
norteamericano es cuando los eeuu dicen
yo ya no tengo nada que hacer aquí
porque mi objetivo está cubierto y voy a
entre comillas fingir que voy a
democratizar afganistán cuando realidad
tampoco lo hace y en ese momento cuando
empezar a negociar con los talibanes
allá por hace como unos 8 o 10 años y
aproximadamente la mitad del tiempo que
llevan allí los
expertos en terrorismo de la zona le
avisan a eeuu evidentemente el talibán
se está infiltrando nuevo a la sociedad
porque eeuu imponiendo una política que
no está arraigada en lo que son las
tradiciones preislámicas incluso el
pasto un wal y pastún con la relación
con pakistán de los azares de loiu de
corderos trágicos sea algo muy complejo
en el afganistán y en irak como ocurrido
también ocurrió con el da es
evidentemente dejó hacer al da es porque
se consideraba que era un movimiento
terrorista que afectaba a otros
territorios el momento en el que eeuu
como otros países deciden enfrentarse al
da es el daes perece muere en pocos
meses porque porque no era un ejército
en el movimiento globalizado terrorista
y en cuanto a lo de las milicias en eeuu
hay un pequeño problema y es que el fbi
los considera un problema interno pero
de seguridad nacional por tanto la
aplicación de la inteligencia que hasta
ese momento no podía hacerse sobre
ciudadanos norteamericanos ahora sí se
puede hacer al igual que la impunidad de
cualquier norteamericano en el
extranjero que antes no tenía ahora sí
lo tiene tantas fuerzas armadas como
servicio inteligencia la cooperación que
se intenta encontrar en servicio
diligencia
lo estamos probando en europa
frenéticamente y genera cosas tan
sumamente
dramáticas como el fallido proyecto
sofía de control de ilícitos en el
mediterráneo por parte la europea que
provoca la presión demográfica y
terroristas y quiero llevarlo hacia la
sahel y que nos lleva hacia marruecos
para las nuevas
tráficos ilícitos hacia el continente
americano y desde el continente
americano hacia toda la ruta del sahel y
para lo cual tiene que hacer un nuevo
proyecto que de sofía para intentar
contrarrestar el incremento del
terrorismo en el sahel es continuamente
estamos poniendo parches cuando realidad
el origen el fundamento
el sistema para atacar un terrorismo el
cualquier terrorismo ya sea extrema
derecha extrema izquierda o terrorismo
de origen religioso es el único la crear
una narrativa convincente comunitaria
compartida y además que sean creíbles la
entrevista social sino jamás llenaremos
a los terroristas y florecerán grupos
por todas partes es verdad lo debo pasar
al último bloque del programa que ya se
nos acaba el tiempo y quiero hablar de
la situación en europa desde los
atentados perpetrados en el 2015 la
unión europea ha venido adoptando
diversas medidas para poder hacer esta
lucha dentro de las fronteras de la
unión europea hay sanciones hay
diferentes tipos de operativos militares
en conjunto entre los diferentes países
y en particular si hay un país que
ha sufrido
ataques terroristas a lo largo de los
últimos años ha sido francia por eso
está con nosotros aquí en el estudio
margot lo allison ella es jefa de
redacción de france 24 en español es
periodista por supuesto está con
nosotros para hacer una radiografía de
lo que ha sucedido en francia y de un
capítulo particular que se está
presentando allí y es que han comenzado
los juicios allí en francia de algunos
de los atacantes que han participado que
han tomado parte de estos ataques que
han tenido lugar en este país europeo
adelante marco claro el lashkar está la
característica de los terroristas e
islámica es de morir en el lugar del
ataque lo que hace que jamás hay juicio
en el caso de los atentados de parís
queda uno que es sala abdelslam
él estaba en parís en esta noche donde
murieron 130 víctimas y él al parecer
renunció a hacerse explotar el juicio
del siglo como la gloria van mucho
empezó al 8 de septiembre pasado y la
justicia francesa tiene nueve meses para
decidirse sobre la sentencia de
abdelslam lo más probable es que esté
condenado a la cadena perpetua pero hay
también cómplices en este caso como
juzgar a los veinte hombres que
brindaron el que brindaron apoyo
logístico al terrorismo habría que
evaluar el grado de complicidad de
cumplir perdón de implicación de esos
cómplices para que la justicia francesa
pueda tomar su decisión otros detalles
hacen que éste desde juicio un momento
histórico y es la cantidad de partido
civil casi 2.000 personas también la
sala de audiencia que fue acomodada
justo para el evento y como lo pueden
imaginar hay condiciones de seguridad
drásticas una cobertura periodística muy
amplia y para concluir sobre este punto
el juicio será grabado lo que ocurre en
francia
en el caso de los juicios históricos
embargo ya hablábamos que este juicio
pues tiene lugar en francia en este
momento coincide este año con la
conmemoración de los 20 años del ataque
del 11 de septiembre en eeuu que lo
estábamos comentando aquí con los
invitados que puente qué relación se
puede hacer entre estos dos hechos
claros jon thiago y si se acuerda fue en
el mes de septiembre pasado que abrió
este juicio justo cuando se conmemoraban
los 20 años de los años de los atentados
del 11 de septiembre nos dice se acuerda
de otro detalle pero después de los
atentados del 11 de septiembre se decía
que este acontecimiento era el que había
hecho entrar el mundo en el siglo 21 y
de alguna manera esos atentados también
son el punto de partida del yihad n con
europa los ataques de noviembre de 2015
estaban muy planeados un poco a la
manera de los del 11 de septiembre ahora
el juicio de los atentados de parís es
calificado como el juicio del siglo
quizás sería un poco dudoso a hablar de
puente entre entre ambos hechos pero
cierto es que el terrorismo islamista ha
marcado nuestro siglo con eso uno se
puede detener a mirar las diferentes
respuestas judiciales entre europa y
eeuu si se acuerda después del 11 de
septiembre la potencia norteamericana
respondió con el secuestro de miles de
sospechosos a través del mundo
encarcelando les en su campo militar de
guantánamo en cuba por ejemplo
luego le lejos de cualquier control y
hace diez años en mayo de 2011 con la
muerte de osama ben laden quien fue
abatido
en su casa por los servicios de
seguridad estadounidense su cuerpo fue
tirado en el mar para evitar cualquier
culto sobre el juicio de parís leia en
un editorial del periódico francés le
monde hace unos meses que este juicio es
la prueba que se puede juzgar
democráticamente el terrorismo en
francia habrá que esperar hasta mayo de
2022 para conocer la respuesta de la
justicia frente a lo que fue sin duda
alguna para los franceses un profundo
trauma un profundo trauma que todavía
está por cerrarse y no solamente afectó
a los franceses afectó a muchos
ciudadanos europeos margot muchas
gracias por haber hecho este análisis
para nosotros y le preguntó entonces a
nuestros invitados a cristian en la
ciudad de barcelona sobre si francia
entonces puede sentar una especie de
precedente de juzgar a los terroristas
algo que no tiene presidente en eeuu y
por lo menos en estos años de lucha el
terrorista a nivel internacional
bueno yo diría que sí que hay
antecedentes ahora los compañeros se
corregirán se me equivoco pero juicios a
personas que han perpetrado atentados
terroristas y teniendo en cuenta la
diversidad de las características y
motivaciones de estos perros de estos
atentados ha habido ha habido varios y
en españa' mismo tendría que ha sufrido
el terrorismo pues también también los
ha habido
quisiera hacer hincapié para quizás
también y cerrándola las ideas que
estamos transmitiendo en esta
conversación toma una palabra de lo
último que dijo fernando cohecho la
necesidad de una narrativa y de una
narrativa no sólo atractiva sino que sea
creíble y aquí creo que efectivamente
este es el este es el reto que tenemos
en todos los países en el mundo y en la
medida que la narrativa para ser creíble
sea
transparente y se pueda
mediar por los medios de comunicación y
la sociedad civil estado social de
derecho en definitivamente pues es eso
lo que nos permite avanzar en esa
dirección claro fernando su opinión
sobre esta lucha en europa los pasos que
ha dado la unión europea muy puntual por
favor porque me quedan pocos minutos
bueno evidentemente será un juicio
histórico en francia pero no olvidemos
que hay sectores franceses por ejemplo
están dirigidos intelectualmente por
gente como hablan de benoit que son de
la extrema derecha lleva mucho tiempo
avisando de una revolución silenciosa
que intentaría subvertir lo que era
sistema estatal también en francia hasta
64 hubo atentados terroristas por parte
de franceses de las aguas y eso es antes
de ayer en realidad el problema del
terrorismo en este caso en francia que
ha golpeado tan fuerte es la costumbre
de ser un país como otros países de
creerse invulnerables que crees en las
lides de lo que es la defensa
democrática y en eso nos hemos
equivocado no francia sino toda europa
pensando que los que vienen no se deben
de adaptar los que vienen son diferentes
y por tanto la narrativa no es correcta
ya quienes el estudio france24
rápidamente oscar su conclusión de este
tema pues cada país tiene definiciones
diferentes de lo que es terrorismo cada
país mira quiénes son y quiénes no son
terroristas en colombia por ejemplo
hemos tenido muchos juicios en contra de
terroristas miembros de organizaciones
guerrilleras que practican el terrorismo
miembros de regiones criminales que
planteen el terrorismo y si hay algo que
es importante seguir estudiando de aquí
en adelante y es esto que mencionan
nuestros colegas en españa' del
terrorismo que llamamos de extrema
derecha que realmente es un concepto muy
amplio que incluye una gran cantidad de
elementos desde el antisemitismo hasta
la islamofobia
y eso está creciendo y hay que verlo muy
muy seguidamente tarde me queda un
minuto para terminar el programa
conclusiones rápidamente oscar en el
estudio que sigue para la lucha
antiterrorista ahora que comenzamos el
2022 en unas cuantas semanas
y cooperación una cooperación muy grande
entre los diferentes estados en
diferentes regiones sobre todo en ese
nivel regional los estados tienen que
trabajar muy muy muy de servirá para
avanzar en esa lucha esto fernando su
conclusión en madrid' rápidamente por
favor pues lo mismo en cooperación
internacional cooperación entre
servicios una narrativa creíble y por
supuesto una tradición democrática que
demuestre que es mejor que otro tipo de
tradiciones y kristen en barcelona para
el cierre
implicación de la sociedad civil en los
retos de seguridad que se halla la
cooperación también entre actores de
seguridad clásica para entenderlo sí y
el conjunto de la sociedad bueno pues se
tienen ustedes las opiniones de nuestros
invitados ustedes puede seguir dejando
sus preguntas y sus comentarios a través
de las redes sociales a cristian a
fernando a buscar en el estudio y por
supuesto a margot por su análisis
gracias por haber estado con nosotros y
haber compartido este tema con nuestros
televidentes ustedes pueden seguir con
la programación de france 24
[Música]